market chains like Costco and Kroger are
now limiting how much meat shoppers can
buy during the pandemic supplies are
starting to run short after virus
outbreak for some meat processing plants
too close employees are returning to
work this week after the president
ordered plants to stay open to prevent
shortages Dean Reynolds is following the
story jbs plants and a Tyson facility
are among the meat processors partially
reopening this week jbs says it will
ramp up safety precautions while Tyson
says workplaces will be retrofitted with
partitions and thermometers we have
secured the personal protective
equipment for Smithfield and we also
will make sure the contact tracing
happens as well South Dakota governor
Kristi Noem is providing equipment and
free testing to the Smithfield pork
plant in Sioux Falls were more than
eight hundred workers tested positive
for the virus if we don't take control
of the meat processing plants obviously
is hidden to entire communities getting
sick
Axl 4 went as executive director of the
rural community workers Alliance in
Missouri is suing Smithfield alleging
workers were not properly protected
Smithfield issued a statement saying in
part it has a policy of not commenting
on the specifics of pending litigation
we are doing everything in our power to
help protect our team members from kovat
19 in the workplace Smithfield says
there will be new protocols including
physical barriers between workers plus
temperature checks do you think there's
going to be more of these plants though
where they just have to shut them down
because these are turning into hot spots
well they should close it down if you
want to prevent is spreading this virus
they should not be working now
supermarkets are trying to avoid what
they call panic buying by placing those
limits on the sale of meat but experts
say there are going to be some shortages
anyway because the processing plants
won't all come back to work at once Tony
all right Dean Reynolds Forrest Dean
thank you very much the